[Applause]
you're watching white here's a little
taste of what we'll be bringing you over
the next 10 minutes
Angela hits the beach to find out how a
new game could help rescue the ocean I
get a lesson from a 17 year old world
drone racing champion and we've got what
our reviewer says is the most unique
game of 2017 welcome to white if you're
a regular guy you know you've probably
already heard about our environmental
campaign called ocean rescue we know a
set that the start of thing you help
educate people about the rising level of
plastic in our seas it's an issue that's
close to our heart which is why this
week Allison has been to meet one lady
she's highlighting plastic pollution by
of gaming 23 year old Daisy Kendrick
started we are the oceans to appeal to
Millennials on their terms
now with the backing of the UN she is
working with one of the biggest game
developers and distributors in the world
the aim to bring together the message
about the ocean and its importance to
the connected generation she's working
with the teams behind the worldwide hit
mobile game Angry Birds to get that
message across so we partnered with
Rovio's to put our games onto their
platform giving existing gamers on Angry
Birds the opportunity to learn about
oceans we've actually had the highest
percentage rate of people clicking to
learn and play about oceans of any other
partnership review of them before
eight million tons of plastic flows into
the ocean each year and it's predicted
outweigh the number of fish in the sea
by 2050 now Angry Bird has had three
billion downloads and it's hoped that by
utilizing these enormous gaming
platforms that it will educate people
about the important environmental issues
and encourage them to do more the big
catch get players to collect as many
different plastics as possible along the
way fact pop-up about why they are
damaging to our oceans players
contribute towards a collective target
to remove 1 million pounds of virtual
plastic and at the end of the game
they'll be a pop up with more
information about the plastic topic and
a link directly to our website asking
people to sign up and learn more so for
us more line in developing state scheme
which is about carbon emissions and sea
levels rising we've had over 65,000
pledges of people committing to reduce
their carbon footprint plastic kills
hundreds of thousands of fish and
seabirds every year and scientists are
concerned it will have direct
implications on human health by acting
as a sponge for toxins which are eaten
by fish and then work their way up the
food chain with millions of people
playing games every day it's hoped the
ocean pollution message will reach this
audience on their terms and drive change
Angela bonds Sky News and if you want
the follow size ocean rescue campaign
take a look at our website guy ocean
rescue dot-com now stay with us if you
or your children can see a future in
Jerome racing I'll be getting tips from
a teenage world champion coming right up
after a roundup of this week's tech news
a competition has been launched to find
new technology that could identify
possible terrorists and protect people
from attack the government hopes the
scheme will improve surveillance in
crowded spaces up to two million pounds
will be made available to fund further
research into the tag Apple's faizon's
had a method for iPhone users to
secretly phone the police when it isn't
safe to physically make the call it
means in the future users could make an
online call with a sequence of
fingerprints for example Atari has
revealed what its first games console
for 24 years looks like the company
emailed fans to say it would feature
modern internal specs so we can deliver
new games as well as classics from its
back catalogue and how did you celebrate
world emoji day earlier this week
these guys were among fans all over the
world can set the first Guinness World
Records title for the largest gathering
of people dressed as emoji faces at the
same time o
proj alert stick around for our games
review in just a few minutes the
multiplayer that changed everything is
back but first
have you ever heard of banning UK that's
what he's known as in a drone racing
community but soon his mom and dad his
Luke banister he's 17 he's a world
champion and while he was in London's
between competing in Shanghai and the US
I caught up with him for a chat about
what he done essentially I race drones
and we called them STD drones position
sliding through first verse of years it
was fitting inside the drone to these on
the average Joe inspect smaller than the
sort filming journalist be at a shop or
whatever and they're much faster much
more maneuverable and we had total
control over them it's the current drone
racing technology pretty up-to-date the
drone takes all a bit behind I mean the
motor take the speed control of
Technology which is like controls the
motors is pretty up there but the
cameras and the video transmission
systems are still sort of redesigned
surveillance systems using analog
frequencies but we're starting to see
high-definition systems which we can
flight or coming into the market so
moving in which we have motors speed
controls and flight controller this will
relate the main system which controls
power slides what about the future of
the technology with drone racing now
what what can you see happening I think
when VR comes in you can start recording
with 360 cameras and they'll give a
really amazing spectator experience
seeing ups that look around the drone as
we're flying as we're racing other
drones but another thing which will
improve during racing is the battery
technology right now we're using lithium
polymer batteries and we're slowly
getting better batteries but that's
really our main thing that's holding us
back right now is there money involved
in these competitions um it depends
around the UK there's already much money
involved I've so fun racing but with the
grassroot - the war friends here and but
usually a more international competition
there's money involved but really I do
it for the fun of it and the enjoyment
of racing but you get to keep the prize
money what does that go to the team dead
to keep the prize money and some of it
goes back to back into the team which is
good to help support us various races
any subbing drone races out there what
would you is top so we hit fee say
firstly when you start get something
like this which is the perfect toy drone
stands for it's like a smaller those
Nevada basically smooth erosion
scaled-down bits in it is it really easy
to you
very easy to slide could I fly it here
we go well I gotta go push forward and
along at all although that's alright
what was your second and third tip see
suppose my second tip would be practiced
in house farmers and my third it would
be when you're looking to build a drone
of this size go on YouTube that some
videos out there to help you learn and
you should find it pretty easy out of
interest what a levels these studies I'm
studying math physics and chemistry
saying there isn't a drone racing a
level right oh I'll be pretty easy here
we go coming down coming down move the
subtle even lower landed five I reckon
there's probably still room to some
improvement there video games time now
in this week Simon has been back in the
studio here is with his pick at the
latest releases yonder the cloud catcher
chronicles which is actually quite a
mouthful to say for the ps4 and PC is
probably going to be the most unique and
the most original game you play in 2017
now the reason for this is no combat in
the game at all you never even asked to
punch anybody in the face or kick
anybody in the stomach the whole reason
to exist here is the village needs your
help and you help out that village by
doing some farming or doing some chores
or just solving some puzzles that's it
that's all you do
at first the island kingdom may seem
however because of that it becomes
incredibly engaging incredibly charming
and you find yourself falling into this
pattern you help villages out and they
come up and thank you and then you do
some more stuff for the villages and
they thank you again it's almost like
this routine that you fall into it if
you were going to work every day before
long you played it for 20 hours you like
for the hell that go so yonder is
wonderful if you're a type of person
that wants to find a game that's utterly
different this is for you I strongly
recommend that you go and check it out
call a duty 4 modern warfare remastered
for the ps4 and Xbox one is the shooter
that came out back in 2007 reimagine for
the modern day can you believe it even
though it is 10 years old it's still one
of the best shooters that's ever been
released in the history of video games
better still if you only got into call
of duty after this game was released you
can go back to it now and still get a
massive kick out of it it hasn't aged
that badly if you're looking for a trip
down memory lane this is perfect I tell
you if you did play it back in 2007 and
enjoyed it then you're going to revisit
it now and still think it's the best of
the entire series and that is saying
something it is a little bit pricey
given that it is just a remaster for
that size it's still a wonderful
experience and again it's the best
shooter ever made arguably and it's
something to consider
minecraft Season 2 episode 1 that is
called a hero in residence is the second
series of tell tales very successful
minecraft story mode and while you study
exactly what Ceaser 1 did that's why it
sound good that's why it's so fancy it's
never too intense you meant to play it
on a Sunday afternoon while you're
relaxing back in a chair much like a
Disney movie has been designed for
parents to play it with their kids
because all kids do love Minecraft and a
parent can enjoy this as opposed to when
a child does play minecraft and just
spend hours building blocks and other
strange creation don't worry
you like Minecraft you want to enjoy it
in a different format or enjoy a
different way of approaching it
that's what telltale sign here nice it's
easy it's simple don't play
that's it for this week's shows don't
forget you can catch up with any of our
five episodes on the line and all the
usual places and follow us on twitter at
tiny flight
i'll be back next time see you then bye
bye
[Applause]